bonjour fois de mon col merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france il y a donc cet
appel à se mobiliser dans le centre
ville de beyrouth
est ce que vous comprenez les raisons
pour lesquelles se tient cette
manifestation anti-gouvernementale
aujourd'hui tout d'abord chère madame je
vais vous dire qu'aujourd'hui au liban
on ne dit pas une histoire normal on vit
une tragédie
on vit un cauchemar on vit une
apocalypse qui a détruit la moitié de la
capitale pour ne pas dire plus il n'y a
pas une personne qu'on connaît au liban
ou à l'étranger qui n'a pas perdu un
membre de sa famille un ami des blessés
jusqu'à maintenant on a plus que 80
personnes qu'on ne sait pas où ils sont
en grande partie qui seront morts ou qui
ont été déchiquetés donc vraiment je
comprends très bien ce mouvement et
j'espère qui s'agrandit de plus en plus
finalement ce mouvement ce mouvement
n'est pas pour simplement un changement
ministériel ou de gouvernement mais
c'est plutôt un changement de toute la
classe politique est demandé aujourd'hui
par le peuple libanais j'aimerais
rappeler et dire à haute voix
aujourd'hui les les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui de tous les partis
politiques qui sont au pouvoir au liban
c'est exactement les mêmes ont détruit
le liban durant quinze ans de guerre
fratricide entre eux et c'est même là
qui ont repris le pouvoir durant 30 ans
et dure entre en ondes et lapider les
fonds et ont détruit le liban qu
économiquement et socialement et c'est
même là c'est eux qui sont responsables
directement ou indirectement de la
catastrophe est de sept explosions
quelle que soit l'origine c'est une
explosion qui s'est passé au port de
béryte est aux mains des politiciens
libanais ils sont moins des partis
politiques libanais on sait très bien
que le port est un terrain public donc
là l'entière responsabilité et à toute
la classe politique et je dis bien aux
pouvoirs exécutif législatif du plus
haut de l'échelle jusqu'au plus bas
donc je comprends vraiment ces jeunes et
je vous dis en tant que chef
d'entreprise j'espère que ce mouvement
est encore plus loin parce qu'on a
besoin d'un changement
et très honnêtement on a complètement
perdu confiance j'ai entendu votre
reportage vous dites pourquoi on veut
une enquête internationale c'est parce
qu'on n'a aucune confiance que les
personnes qui sont directement ou
indirectement responsable de l'explosion
sont eux mêmes qu'ils soient pas les
juges et enfin de temps les coupables et
les avocats donc voilà pourquoi
évidemment on n'a aucune confiance en ce
pouvoir de tout genre
vous vous tenez donc les dirigeants vos
dirigeants libanais comme responsable de
cette explosion
madame ils sont directement responsables
et je vous dit pourquoi
tout d'abord le port de beyrouth est
arrêtée d'un terrain public donc sous
contrôle de l'état à tous les niveaux
on doit dire que finalement ce qui s'est
passé était équivalent à une bombe
atomique
ses 3000 ou 4000 tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium qui ont été stoppé durant
cinq ans c'était ça a été pris par les
services de renseignements par l'armée
par autres je ne sais pas comment c'est
passé mais finalement cette paire maison
était présente au port de beyrouth
durant cinq ans on dormait sur une bombe
atomique sans le sans le savoir
et finalement quelle que soit l'origine
ce qui a explosé c'est cette période
étaient présents dans le port de
beyrouth et c'était un risque à tous les
habitants les banner qui ont payé le
prix oui madame qui sont directement
responsables encore une fois s'ils sont
directement responsables
c'est une tragédie et qui sont
indirectement responsable n'apporte pas
de chéquier ou pour corruption ou
revendre c'est encore pire donc dans
l'espace oui je vous dis ils plantèrent
responsabilité toute la classe politique
et je dis bien non seulement la classe
politique est aujourd'hui mais la classe
politique qui s'est succédé
on sait très bien que ce port de
beyrouth il accueille doublement une
économie claire et propre qui est les
produits d'import export de matériel
mais en même temps c'est très bien c'est
aussi le fief de l'import export de
l'économie noire on sait que c'est le
fief de la corruption je vous dis toutes
les personnes responsables dans les
places publiques ces deux personnes qui
ont été placées par les politiciens qui
ont été placés par des groupes
politiques pour pouvoir vraiment garder
ses frontières cette frontière maritime
et autres frontières comme des passoires
pour des points politiques ou autres
donc oui je vous redis j'ai insiste en
tant que président des chefs
d'entreprises deba né dans le monde en
tant que p conomique oui ils sont
entièrement responsables et on a besoin
on a besoin de la communauté
internationale pour nous aider pour nous
aider à les suivre
je dirais même d'être jugé pour crimes
contre l'humanité qui s'est passé madame
c'est pas seulement un crime on est
libanais mais c'est un crime contre
l'humanité et encore une fois nous en
tant que libanais au liban le monde
on ne peut pas faire ça seul on ne va
pas faire une autre guerre on ne peut
pas le faire mais on a besoin de la
communauté internationale pour nous
aider à suivre ça et c'est ce qu'on
espère de plus on a eu le président
français on reçoit aujourd'hui
internationale ait présenté emmanuel
macron vous disiez étaient sur place il
ya quelques jours et aujourd'hui c'est
charles michel le président du conseil
européen qui est arrivé à beyrouth
leur présence est importante pour vous
pour le peuple libanais écoutez madame
d'abord la présence et la visite du
président macron a été extrêmement bien
accueilli je sais pas si vous êtes bien
sûr vous avez très bien couvert ça il a
donné beaucoup d'espoir mais il a aussi
dit que je ne peux pas je suis président
de la france et non trois présidents du
liban je peux donc donner un support
messaoudi panier de faire le grand
travail et la performance sont
aujourd'hui on a besoin de trois formes
de support on a bien sûr besoin en
priorité un support pour encore sauver
des vies si on le peut on a besoin d'un
support humanitaire parce qu'on va avoir
on a des manques de médicaments comme
vous l'avait dit dans votre reportage
cette explosion j'ai passé au coeur de
beyrouth dont kadhafi par des hôpitaux
ont été détruits ils seront manque de
médicaments mais aussi en pièces de
rechange de supports à savoir qu'on
vivait une crise sociale et économique
une crise de devises
déjà bien avant on a besoin d'un support
international pour faire finalement
cette enquête qu'on aimerait vraiment
savoir ce qui s'est passé et comment ça
s'est passé parce que une fois de plus
on ne fait pas confiance aux halles en
quête des principales pour savoir que
c'est très clair qu'ils vont se couvrir
l'un les autres comme ils l'ont fait
durant toutes les les trente années où
ils sont orange gouvernement et trois
oui on a besoin d'un support
international non seulement pour la
reconstruction mais pour la
reconstruction de l'économie des
familles des maisons et à savoir qu'on a
une grande crise de devises donc c'est
même impossible de pouvoir investir dans
les matières premières dans des produits
de première nécessité aux autres donc
cette aide internationale doivent être à
plusieurs niveaux évidemment un niveau
politique au niveau sécuritaire et
humanitaire et je vais ajouter un point
extrêmement important
la seule pression qu'on peut mettre
aujourd'hui sur les politiciens libanais
c'est une pression internationale pour
geler leurs comptes
à l'extérieur le seul moyen qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui et pouvoir les sortir
de leur zone de confort et la zone de
confort
c'est nécessaire nous suivent toutes les
personnes ils sont également accusés de
corruption parce que je vous dise ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui au port ça peut
être une erreur humaine ça peut être
mais quelles que soient ses liés à de la
corruption parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on
a trois mille tonnes de nitrates qui
sont cachés ou bien de façon encore une
fois volontaire ou involontaire c'est à
dire que c'est lié directement à la
corruption et s'est imposée
que ce soit les corrompus qui combattent
eux-mêmes la corruption comme m merci
beaucoup
fouad zmokhol pour tous ces éléments de
réponse merci pour cet éclairage vous
rappelle que vous êtes président du
rassemblement des dirigeants et chefs
d'entreprise libanais